Samantha power where did you get the
title for your book a problem from hell
eh I took it from Warren Christopher's
statement during the war in Bosnia when
he described the hatred between the
groups in the former Yugoslavia is
almost unbelievable almost terrifying it
was a problem from hell which implied
that there was nothing much we on the
outside could do about it your subtitle
on the book is America and the age of
genocide where did the word genocide
come from genocide is one of my great
discoveries and the course of writing
this book was that it's a recent
invention and innovation you would have
thought that the word had been with us
as long as the crime you know back from
the Bible forward but in fact it was a
Polish Jew named Raphael Lemkin who'd
lost 49 members of his family who
decided he was going to devote the rest
of his life after the Holocaust to
banning a crime that was then called
barbarity and he said to himself you
know I need a word that somehow connotes
the evil that we're describing and he
you know went through his notebooks and
so on he tested out a bunch of other
different expressions before and finally
in 1944 he settled upon the word
genocide and he had fled Poland which
was his homeland and gone via Latvia
Lithuania and Sweden and ended up in the
United States so he's actually working
for the State Department here the War
Department in 1944 when he coined this
term and he then spent the rest of his
life first of all try to give it into
Webster's and the OED and larousse and
all the dictionaries but then recognized
he was a lawyer and he recognized that a
word a free-floating word that connoted
evil but that didn't commit anybody to
doing anything about it wasn't enough so
what he did for years after coining the
word is draft the first ever UN human
rights treaty which was the Genocide
Convention and then he spent the rest of
his life he died in that from 1959
trying to get the Genocide Convention
through the UN General Assembly and then
most fundamentally and most crucially
through the US Senate which he actually
failed to do what does genocide mean
very controversial obviously to this day
raphael lemkin notwithstanding the
definition settled upon in the UN treaty
is a systematic attempt to destroy in
whole or
substantial part and national ethnic or
religious group as such so the idea here
is that you don't have to exterminate
every last member of a group to commit
genocide if you just intent to wipe out
the group as a meaningful entity on a
territory that's enough so it's more
expansive than our associations with ur
which which are with the Holocaust when
did genocide start in the world the
practice again Genesis I think it's been
with us forever there's a tendency of
groups who feel themselves under siege
who feel like they're risking losing
something either because a minority
group is claiming their rights and and
usually there's some kind of economic
dislocation and some kind of catalysts
in terms of you know a plane crash or
the outbreak of war genocide often
happens under the cover of war but where
one group sets out to systematically
destroy another group either by
murdering everybody as Hitler did and as
the Rwandan who to set out to do or as
in Bosnia by ethnically deporting an
entire populace namely the Bosnian
Muslims killing a huge number of them
because the only way to get rid of a
populace is to convince them that
returning would mean a death sentence
and degrading the women by setting up
rape camps and other things I mean the
lots of sort of forms the genocide has
taken over time and I think one of the
problems that lemken has encountered or
that his legacy has encountered is that
people do associate the word genocide
with the Holocaust and there's a
tendency to sort of say you know we
can't use the word until it's six
million or until we have fool proof that
the perpetrator group is setting out to
exterminate every last member and it
just would make Lumpkin turn over in his
grave because he was so adamant that the
Holocaust not be the standard because
obviously then preventive action if it
were to come would necessarily come too
late there's a picture of a person that
we've seen a lot here in this town but
it said earlier in his life picture a
senator by the name of William Proxmire
why is he in your book well after lemkin
died in 1959 the Genocide Convention
which had been ratified by just about
every Western democracy languished in
the United States the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee wanted to a part of
a number of southern senators were
actually afraid that they would be
hauled up on genocide charges because of
Jim Crow and lynchings and and
segregation more generally and they
thought the language in the Convention
was too expansive and so they basically
torpedoed the convention and lemkin dies
i mentioned 1959 eight years later
William Proxmire took up Lumpkins cause
became a kind of Lemke knee and Crusader
my main goal in this book is for the
word limb Kenny and to become an
adjective to describe single-minded
monomaniacal obsessive-compulsive
humanitarian and proxmire became that he
stood up on the Senate floor in 1967 and
he said I'm gonna give a speech a day
for as long as it takes to get this
convention through it I can't believe
that the US Senate could not have
ratified this law it's a genocide
convention for crying out loud and he
said each speech is going to be
different and he thought in his mind it
would take six months a year he thought
it was a legislative quirk well 19 years
3211 original speeches later Proxmire a
little creepier at the joints was still
standing still giving his ritual speech
a day with it you know in the hopes of
getting this convention through you said
that was took by the time the United
States approve the Geneva I've been the
Genocide Convention it was the 98th
country or something like they're
absolutely yeah and you know what's very
interesting is how the ratification
actually came about because
unfortunately I wish I could say it was
Lumpkin and Proxmire teaming up and
these two kind of zany you know kind of
Cassandra figures had had succeeded in
bringing enough people around but it
actually was and it's very important the
reason that the ratification came about
was for very very political reasons
Ronald Reagan you might remember visited
the SS graves in Bitburg or he visited
the the cemetery of bitburg in West
Germany and there were SS soldiers who
were buried there there was a firestorm
of protest in the United States I mean
protests in 15 American cities with tens
of thousands of people coming out jewish
groups veterans group labor groups
church groups people really unhappy with
reagan and even though he knew that this
outrage was was brewing he went ahead
and and and proceeded with the trip
because he wasn't one to back down under
public pressure and people said off you
know your reputations really suffered
there is this public outrage
and as soon as he got back he summoned
to his oval office lieutenant colonel on
the National Security Council staff
incidentally named oliver north and he
said wasn't there a genocide convention
lying around somewhere and North said
yes sir there what there was and there
is and it's in the center of
formulations chamilia no and no
president has really invested any
political capital and getting it through
the committee there's this crazy guy
proxmire has been standing up in
yammering for the last 19 years and
reaganzilla let's do it and within the
year it had cleared the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee and come up for a
full vote in the Senate and there it did
very very well we attached a number of
reservations to it the kind of protected
American soldiers and and and political
leaders so sort of undermine the
ratification but at least it came about
and what we would see of course in that
in the 1990s when genocide would happen
is that even though we detach these
reservations US officials within the
government and advocates outside use the
convention and used America's signature
signature finally belated signature to
try to generate a response on the
grounds that we had committed ourselves
to doing so you have over 600 pages 14
chapters I'm going to quickly read some
of the chapters 6 Cambodia helpless
giant 8 Iraq human rights and chemical
weapons use aside 9 Bosnia no more than
witnesses at a funeral 10 Rwanda mostly
in a listening mode 11 schreiber anika
getting creamed is the subtitle 12
Kosovo a dog and a fight what what are
the why are these the names of chapters
what is the purpose well most of the
chapter times they're all a little bit
different in terms of where the
quotations come from but they tend to be
from US government documents one of the
things i had the great privilege of
doing was working with the National
Security Archive a a non-governmental
group based here in Washington to use
the Freedom of Information Act to get
these documents declassified so i just
took advantage of the collection that
they had amassed worked with them and
and sort of when i had conducted an
interview and learned about a document
would tell them about it but they really
do the heavy lifting
and these documents you would just see
in very very sterile cold bureaucratic
language phrases like human rights and
chemical weapons use aside comma Saddam
Hussein really looks like he can be a
reliable partner in the Middle East you
know the Kosovo title that you mentioned
a dog and a fight was my sort of play on
words because James Baker had said in
relationship to the war in Bosnia very
much like Warren Christopher's
characterization of it as a problem from
hell Baker had said we don't have a dog
in that fight and in Kosovo we had a dog
or perceived ourselves to have a dog and
consequently we had a fight how did you
get into this first place I was a
reporter a young reporter pretty
idealistic in Bosnia during the war
there I went over in 1993 for the first
time and left finally in 1996 writing
for writing for stringing for US News
and World Report and the economist and
then my last year for the Washington
Post and I was it was hard to do there
was an incredible community of
journalists there that were very
embracing for somebody who didn't know
what she was doing and but it was very
hard because the NATO planes are flying
overhead every day and there and they're
monitoring what is going on but they're
not intervening they're not stopping it
and I fell especially once I was able to
write for the post and cover some big
stories for them that I was at the
height of my potential power as a
journalist even if I were a staff
correspondent the best I could do as a
foreign correspondent would be to be
writing on the front page of the
Washington Post during a big foreign
news story and it seemed to be doing no
good whatsoever so I left bosnia
actually initially in September 95 and
decide to go to law school thinking that
I would try to prosecute the bad guys
and who really were bad and who had just
committed the largest single massacre in
Europe and 50 years the massacre you
mentioned in in rubber neatza and I came
back very sort of disputed about the
power of the pen very dispiriting about
the united states and foreign policy
clinton had made a whole series of
commitments in the campaign about what
he was going to do and
and one my love as a result of my vote
and you know when he got into office he
just decided that the costs of
engagement were much greater than the
non costs of staying uninvolved and when
I returned the United Sates ironically
literally the day I got to Boston to go
to law school NATO intervened and it was
only through reporting for this book and
doing the other side of the story so not
what was going on in Bosnia but the
policy story that I realized why that
intervention had come about which is
really very much about American domestic
politics which is the thesis of the book
which is the battle to stop genocide is
lost in their own domestic politics and
that is where it can be won if it's to
be one but we did bomb and I and I just
why I was in law school I just spent my
early months they're just trying to
figure out why the Bosnian Muslims had
been so excluded from the universe of
moral obligation and why it was that
everywhere I went even in Boston the
remembrance of the Holocaust which was
so important and which was kind of
building to a crescendo there were more
Holocaust related news stories in the
first five years of the 1990s than in
the previous 45 years combined the
Holocaust Museum of course had opened up
on the on the mall in Washington and
this seemed very appropriate you know
boom in remembrance and and
commemoration but it didn't seem to
translate into any kind of cognitive or
moral dissonance even though we had just
allowed these people in my judgment
anyway to die for three and a half years
so what the book was an effort to do was
to sort of figure out what made the
Bosnian Muslims different you know if we
said never again and we meant it why
didn't we mean it for them it didn't
take me long to realize that actually we
done more for the Bosnian Muslims than
any victim of genocide in the 20th
century in fact and that was sort of
jarring for me to realize that as
frustrating as it had been to see the
NATO planes flying overhead and these
little boys and girls getting picked off
their bicycles and men herded into
concentration camps and to feel that we
could have done something to later
realize that even the mere act of having
planes fly overhead to the extent that
it deterred it was the greatest
deterrence and greatest investment
in preventing or deterring genocide that
this country had made uh your boss Co
was Harvard it was yeah what year did
you get your autograph well I took a
year off in the middle of it to work on
the books on 99 where'd you get your
undergraduate degree Yale College your
hometown is were complications I
immigrated to this country with my my
family came in 1979 when I was nine and
we're from from from Ireland from Dublin
and I went to high school in Atlanta
Georgia and then began moving around
once I went to college why from Ireland
why did they come here there was no
divorce in Ireland back then actually
it's a very recent innovation and my
parents were splitting up so my mother
came over with my stepfather and this
was a land of the free and you could
freely disengage from past commitments
so and we stayed you had to stay here i
think five years to get a divorce but we
ended up just staying forever and where
do you hang your hat now winthrop
massachusetts doing what uh watching a
lot of Red Sox baseball games now that
I'm finished with this beast of a book
and I run something called the car
center for human rights policy it's
something that I founded with a
tremendous entrepreneur named Greg Carr
who invented voicemail and who decided
that what the world needed was not
necessarily more human rights groups and
more advocacy and more documentation of
abuses what it needed was a kind of
Human Rights policy think tank or you
could actually reflect on what works and
what doesn't both in terms of
governmental policy and in terms of NGO
advocacy and this book in many ways is a
real outgrowth of that kind of thinking
I mean it's an effort to not just lament
US policy for the last hundred years but
really try to understand what is it that
makes it tick and and what is it that
makes each of the individual actors tick
within it in the face of these
enormities but but anyway this car
center for human rights policy i hope
will be with us for a very long time i'm
actually leaving the position of
executive director but michael ignatieff
who I'm sure has been on your program in
the past
is the faculty director and this will
Shepherd it into the the next generation
of human rights crises what are you
doing then I'm going to take some time
off and begin working on new projects
and we'll teach at the Kennedy School
beginning in 2003 philosophically you
mentioned being a journalist writing for
The Washington Post what should a
journalist do in their job as a reporter
should they advocate I don't I don't
think um it's our job to advocate but I
certainly I don't think neutrality in
the face of genocide is appropriate and
appropriate stance either and I think
one of these you see it was very
interesting to go back through other
cases again not my own but Rwanda and
Cambodian some of the other major cases
of genocide is to see journalists
bending over backwards upon being
greeted with the unthinkable that is
atrocities of this scale just sort of do
not compute but upon being greeted with
that immediately because of this bias
toward neutrality and because we're all
trained in that way bending over
backwards to try to find atrocities
committed by the victim people against
those sort of alleged perpetrator people
so was to do a kind of two-sided account
well the thing about genocide is that
it's not to sign it I mean you may have
isolated abuses committed by people who
happen to have arms in the victim group
but for the most part as in the case in
Bosnia it was ninety percent of the
atrocities were committed by the Serbs
against non-serbs especially in the
early part of that crisis and yet our
tendency was to say okay well if we dock
if we've reported a massacre against
Muslims let's go find the mass agreeance
serves and I think that was a huge
mistake and you saw journalist overtime
growing out of it at they came to
realize that neutrality and objectivity
are two different things that you don't
actually have to be neutral you do have
to be objective but often objectivity
will take you to a place where you are
telling the story with the proportions
that it that it warrants you have a
cover here of a cemetery where is this
this is the line cemetery and sorry Eve
oh um so I thought it was appropriate
juxtaposition with Warren Christopher's
account
of of the violence in in the former
Yugoslavia that it was insoluble and I
think one of the lessons that one
gathers over the course of the century
in addition to the lesson that lots of
bodies will pile up and there will be
lots of cemeteries whose numbers are you
know expanded dramatically but one of
the lessons is that usually these crimes
are committed by a discreet nameable set
of perpetrators many of whom these days
carry cell phones can be contacted you
know are known we had a US diplomat in
the Rwanda during the Rwanda genocide
where 800,000 people were killed in a
hundred days our deputy assistant
secretary for African affairs prudence
Bushnell had the cell phone numbers of
the perpetrators and would call them up
she would set her alarm for two in the
morning and called them up and say
Colonel bagus or I want you to know that
if you don't stop the genocide the
president will hold you personally
responsible she was told smoke and
mirrors the President had given her any
such instructions but they are nameable
there they are findable and they are
stoppable but it's not something we've
chosen to make a priority just yet you
often tell you the stories in here with
the person and one of those is henry
morgenthau senior who was he and what
what's the story around him henry
morgenthau senior is my first what I've
come to call upstander this is a book
very much about by standing as you know
but um it's told through the incredible
struggles of up standards of people
stand up within or outside the system
and Morgenthau was the US ambassador in
constantinople the capital of the
ottoman empire back in 1915 when the
Turks began to systematically deport and
murder and destroy it's there Armenian
minority and what's interesting about
Morganthau number one is that it took
him a while to move along a kind of
continuum of knowledge I mean I've now
come to see knowledge is as almost
indeterminate that you can have sort of
abstract information and then you sort
of sometimes it takes you a series of
personal encounters either
with refugees with cables with something
that makes that information kind of
become almost knee buckling knowledge
and Morgan that didn't believe the
reports that he was receiving initially
about what was being done there means
who could who would think that that kind
of thing would happen and he had this do
not compute problem that so many of us
have had and then there was a moment
where these missionaries came into his
office with literally tears streaming
down her face and Morgan doesn't like
God it's true isn't it and what had
happened he he had been told that all of
the armenian intellectuals in each of
the major towns being executed in public
squares and that the entire armenian
populace was being deported out into the
desert where no provision was being made
to care for them and where as many as
half would die of disease and starvation
and many were actually killed also along
the way by their alleged escorts so I
think Morgan's out for the as a sort of
foundational character in the book is so
important because it just shows you the
limits of all of our imaginations also
the privilege he had in a way of being
able to have sort of face-to-face
encounters with people who actually you
know with Armenians with Turkish
officials and with missionaries who were
regaling these stories to him but the
other thing you see through Morganthau
is how limited our conception then of
American power because of course we're
firmly isolated it's World War one we
have no intention of forgoing our
neutrality certainly not in the interest
of humanitarian intervention of any kind
but you also see the limits of the kind
of conception of what any government has
a right to ask of another government
meaning Morgan that was just asking the
listen administration can I have
permission to denounce these crimes and
he was told now you can't interfere in
the internal affairs of a sovereign
state so what do you mean I can't
interfere the thoroughfares they're
killing the Armenians no you can you
know diplomatic protocol dictates that
you retain your neutrality in the face
of whatever the host government is doing
and so Morgan that sort of muzzled
himself and finally he just went off the
reservation and and began just issuing
basically private to Marsha's you know
again sort of speaking out of school I'm
not sure what good they did but one of
the things you see over the course of
the centuries how r concept
of what is possible in terms of
intervention if you view interventions
with a small I instead of big military
intervention that back then all Morgan
thought could even deign to hope for was
to be able to denounce whereas in 1999
you know in the in with Kosovo we had
the error intervention and one of the
complaints on this side in Washington
was hey why no ground troops you know in
Bosnia we were arguing for for
airstrikes in Rwanda for radio jamming
and further things you see the kind of
tool kit that that people have on offer
that they can dip into in the face of
genocide that the upstanders are arguing
that we do open and that we start to
experiment with that it gets much more
expansive and we start to be much more
creative about what it is the US
government can do however the US
government tends not to take his Henry
Morgenthau senior the father of henry
morgenthau the FDR's secretary of the
Treasury he is indeed and and his son
was greatly influenced I think by by his
father's experience and that that sense
of impotence and I think one of the
reasons Morganthau jr. was as punitive
as he would become of course he was the
author of the famous you know pastoral
ization plan where was you know the plan
to wipe out German industry yet again
after war two very much against the sort
of Marshall Plan vision for recuperation
but I think you know he had grown up
with these stories of these crimes and
and so medicines like my God if we don't
punish these if we don't actually send a
signal not only to the perpetrators in
hand but to any purpose would be
perpetrator out there in the world who
might be contemplating these kinds of
crimes then it'll come back to haunt us
who's this fellow in this picture oh
that is tellurian tellurian is an
armenian survivor somebody who lost his
entire family in the armenian genocide
and who decides he's so shattered and
he's lost literally everything he joins
a terrorist group one of this century's
first terrorist groups boston-based
actually which was devoted to simply
tracking down the leading perpetrators
of what was then called race murder
cause course lempkin only invented his
word in 1944 Morganthau referred to what
the church were doing his race murder
and to Lyrian was basically contracted
to track down to lot who had been the
Minister of the Interior the Turkish
Minister and the opening scene of the
book not to ruin it for people but is to
Lyrian tracking down to lot in the
streets of Berlin of all places in 1921
and coming up to him pointing revolver
at the back of his head and saying this
is to avenge the death of my family and
killing him how many Armenians were
killed numbers body counts notoriously
difficult to pin down even 87 years
later but somewhere between 800,000 and
1.5 million the number of Armenians that
I've encountered over the course of
speaking about this book and and and
really just traveling around the country
listening to people who have lost you
know grandparents parents it's it's I
can't believe the toll that this that
this has taken and you see it you see on
Armenian remembrance day April 24th you
know Armenians gathering in mass so
devastated by the absence of recognition
unfortunately a denial of the crime that
was committed against their people that
I fear will persist at an official level
certainly the Turkish government is
showing no signs of engaging to have a
conversation about what what they will
admit was done in their name but also in
Washington of course because of our
reliance on the relationship with Turkey
I think there's very little likelihood
that either the White House or even the
Congress will issue the kind of
resolution that the Armenians are
longing for it's amazing I mean limpkin
invented this word actually having read
about what the Turks had done to the
Armenians I mean was literally this was
the thing that made him think I have to
devote my life to banning this crime I'm
a Polish Jew they're pilgrims committed
in my neighborhood all the time I used
to think it was only against Jews that
these crimes were committed now I see
Stephen against Christians it's this
crime it happens through history
biological regularity he would say and
it was really that that got him on his
path toward naming and then and then
banning the crime the word genocide
again it means rice murder in what
language well it's a Greek and Latin
hybrid so it actually means the killing
of a people so the killing of a group
you know Geno's and then some
I'd sadar a and you know we had homicide
we had Regis side we had fratricide and
I'm good today you know why not genocide
but he was he in addition to sort of
being sort of set down his garden path
by what he I reading about tellurian
actually i'm reading about this
assassination because lumpkin set
himself if victims are always stuck
taking justice into their own hands
we're going to live in a lawless world
we have to have some kind of court of
public opinion or actual court that will
weigh in on atrocities committed by
states against their own people because
there's a structural problem if states
are committing the crimes they're not
going to be punishing themselves for
them you say that raphael lemkin who you
write a lot about in the book ended up
penniless in a one-room apartment in the
Upper West Side of New York died what
year 59 Oh Annie was 59 yeah but along
the way you say that this man could be a
real pest who and a lot of people used
to say here he comes and they go out the
other door absolutely that's why Salem
Kenny and he was a leb Kenny and pasty
he was monomaniacal you see this with a
lot of my upstanders the people that
want encounters throughout the century
but people who take a stand tend to not
be the most politically savvy they just
are so single-minded complete tunnel
vision and there's a letter that I that
I have in there that is just I think the
best indicator of lumpkins absence the
absence of social graces he writes to a
woman named Thelma Stevens who has
volunteered her time as everyone did to
work for Lumpkin I mean he had no money
couldn't pay anybody and he went through
law students and and you know church
volunteers like they were going out of
style and there's a letter there that he
that he writes to Thelma Stevens this
methodist council volunteer where she's
devoting her summer to aiding his cause
and he writes her unless she opens up
this letter and it says dear Miss
Stevens I know it must be hot there in
Washington as you're writing this letter
campaign but needless to say it's not
nearly as hot as the ovens of Auschwitz
or the deserts of Aleppo and I urge you
in a sense to get your butt in here
here's this woman she's my your own
business she's doing everything she can
for this man who is
brilliant in his way and prophetic how
do you make money tin tin pot you know
really just rely and he hated I mean the
indignity of it all you know he'd been
he's a very cultured man he wrote apart
from his books on on mass slaughter he
wrote on Rose cultivation on gardening
on you know travel in Japan wherever he
was is a refugee in route here he would
just gobble up the local culture and
he'd been homeschooled he spoke 13
languages did he marry never married
never even dated as far as I can tell
and what did what happened when people
ask him about that what would he say
about his marriage oh I don't have time
you know I'm married to to securing the
banning of the crime of genocide I mean
I don't have time for love the Genocide
Convention today if something happens
and then it can be proved who has to
prove by the way that it's genocide this
is the one of the many structural
problems with Lincoln's law there is no
body that is the arbiter or the
necessary arbiter of whether or not a
genocide is happening lemkin had
proposed that a body be created at the
United Nations comprised of independent
representatives though of member states
who themselves would weigh in on the
evidence that never came into being no
state party of any prominence namely the
United States or any of its allies
wanted to put in place a body that might
in turn judge it or one of its allies so
really the way it happens in practice is
what you get is groups like Human Rights
Watch who become increasingly
professional their lawyers are ever more
trained to go in to a crime scene to
debrief refugees to try to gauge
perpetrators intent because again this
is an intent based crime it's not a
numbers counts not a body count it's
what is the intent of the perpetrator do
they intend to destroy in whole or in
substantial part a group as such and so
you get non-governmental groups and the
best ones again are very good at this
going in quickly and then they
themselves try to get one or more of the
member states to admit that what's going
on is genocide and unfortunately while
lempkin what an achievement that he's
turned this word into this incredible
stigma that there is this convention
that we now of course prosecuting it but
the bittersweet part of his legacy are
the bitter part of the other
bye sweet legacy I suppose is that all
that this sort of stigma has has
succeeded in doing is making States much
more reluctant to admit the genocide as
what is underway so no state wants to be
accused of committing yet but as
interesting no state wants to be seen to
be allowing it so what they do is they
call it a problem from hell what
statesmen do is they say it's a problem
from hell it's ethnic violence it's
civil war these people have been killing
was resilient years nobody uses the word
genocide no sitting president has ever
used the word genocide to describe a
genocide underway only when its past and
the political implications have died
down for the the American leader is the
word employee without lempkin would you
have the Milosevic trial going on right
now in The Hague excellent question um
excellent question i'm not sure i mean
you know presumably there would have
been a push for some kind of
international criminal justice mechanism
over time presumably you know lempkin
didn't have much to do with the the
creation of human rights groups in fact
left Khatib's it gets so impossible he
hated human rights people he thought in
fact he petitioned Eleanor Roosevelt and
the Assistant Secretary of State for
international organizations to exclude
from the universal declaration of human
rights the right to life cuz lumpkin
said that's my right that's in my
convention and he got this very funny
letter back from the assistant secretary
saying I'm sure you'd agree mr. Lumpkin
that the right to life is one of the
more fundamental human rights I think
what you would have seen is a human
rights movement anyway both on the heels
of Eleanor Roosevelt's Universal
Declaration and all the international
law that has grown out of it he would
have seen human rights groups having to
get into the business of documenting
atrocities as well as trying to free
prisoners and doing the things that they
used to do in their early days it helped
though that the Genocide Convention was
the one piece of international law that
had in it a reference to a future
international permanent international
criminal court and of course it was just
in March of 2002 that that are actually
April of 2002 that that criminal court
came into existence and now we're just
in the process of waiting to see whether
it will have any legs and life of its
own especially with American opposition
ask you about people as a way of getting
to tell some of the stories Michael
twining Charles 20 Charles 20 and excuse
me no problem I thought maybe there was
another one that I had girls up I didn't
Charlie twining was again like
Morgenthau it's interesting you
mentioned him but he he was worked at
the US Embassy in Thailand during the
period where Pol Pot ran Cambodia and
during the period where Pol Pot was
wiping out anybody who had hands that
look like they had been in school and
not in the field anybody who wore
eyeglasses anybody who had a seventh
grade education or above this was that
that was that time between 1975 in 1979
his picture better that is the Khmer
Rouge soldier who's taking who's
entering poonam pen in 1975 and who's
very very angry of course the United
States has just been involved in bombing
Cambodia and there's great resentment
toward the regime that was deemed to be
a puppet regime of the united states
that had run cambodia prior to that with
sia nook and lon ol at the helm and what
twining did is he began he went he was
dispatched he spoke Khmer which was
unusual for us official he was
dispatched to the thai Cambodian border
has a very slow but steady trickle of
refugees emerged from Cambodia telling
these stories that were simply
unbelievable you say he spoke the line
he spoke yeah he had earned the sort of
laughter and ridicule of his colleagues
at the State Department while they were
learning Thai and Chinese he was
studying come here and they tell people
why on earth would you be studying Khmer
well it came in handy as he was able to
to mine these refugees of their stories
and but very much like Morganthau at the
beginning in the century he could wrap
his mind around it and 420 was
interesting cuz Morganthau was hearing
these stories before he learned about
the Holocaust there was no Holocaust
there was no precedent for the
systematic destruction of a people for
twining the very fact that he had
learned and been groomed on the
Holocaust I mean having having really
learned to be attentive that these kinds
of crimes could happen
for him he just couldn't believe that he
himself could be living in a time where
history was repeating itself did you
talk to him I did ya know I talked to
any US official I could who would talk
to me I basically tried to track down
over the course of the last six years
and twining was very gracious and
described that process he said look here
I had these reports from these refugees
saying that anyone over seventh grade
education 11 when the seventh grade age
was being murdered I wasn't in a file at
to Washington Oscar look like I was
crazy oh this was nineteen seventy 7576
he was at the border who who is the bad
guy in charge of Cambodia Pol Pot and he
came from where he came from you know a
sort of Maoist radical revolutionary
past he'd gone into rebellion against
the law no government into the
countryside and been waging a guerrilla
war and in april of nineteen seventy
five he and the khmer rouge succeeded in
taking poonam pen just after the United
States left Saigon of course we were the
Khmer Rouge Khmer Rouge were these
radical agrarian revolutionaries who
paid very little attention to the
welfare their people and who in the end
were responsible for the deaths of about
two million or the course of four years
how do we know there are two main again
I'm using that number as shorthand
there's been there's been a significant
number of exclamations and sort of
extrapolate of research done there's
been some census compilation that's been
done but unfortunately as in many of the
places where genocide happens the senses
were pretty incomplete beforehand so
it's hard to do a kind of
before-and-after check but it's yeah you
know having reviewed all of the
statistical surveys that I could that
seems the number that is most agreed
upon by the most respected historians
Paul pod closed that country up for what
how long for three in just over three
years from april nineteen seventy five
until january nineteen seventy-nine and
what was our approach to all this as a
complete shutdown I mean just you know
we've come home at last from Vietnam the
idea of focusing this country's
attention on Cambodia when we clearly
had no intention of sending military
troops to alter the situation on the
ground
and when protests denunciations of these
crimes would it felt like they would be
ineffectual because it was such an
isolated regime I mean as you say he cut
off the country almost entirely the
temptation was to just go again into a
complete sort of cocooned and again the
egregious thing when one looks back is
not that the United States didn't send
its troops back to Southeast Asia having
just come home but I think it's that
when a relationship was developed with
China in the middle part of Pol Pot's
rain with the opening to not even think
about mentioning to China that it's a
lie was committing these abuses because
the Khmer Rouge the only partner it had
was China really in many ARMs and
economic support was coming from Beijing
but again you know genocide doesn't
factor into the thinking of many
American administrations in and of
itself it's not on the list of things to
do how do you know that they didn't talk
to the Chinese back then well I I have
done all the reporting that I was able
to do and I mean one of the things that
we did that the United States did after
the Vietnamese of course dislodged Pol
Pot invaded the country eventually in
and succeeded in ousting the kr and
rescuing people but of course it was a
puppet Vietnamese regime it's kind of a
regime of occupation and because of our
not so nice relationship with Vietnam
our policy afterwards was actually to
continue to recognize the Khmer Rouge
well in two foot foot for the next
decade so even though we had
documentation of the killing of around
two million people the Khmer Rouge
continued to occupy the seat at the
United Nations and Brzezinski and others
in the Carter Administration were you
know quite straight by they just look
the enemy of our enemy may not be our
friend but it can be our diplomatic
partner it is the lesser of Evil's and
the question I think years later that we
have to ask is could there actually have
been an evil greater than that of Pol
Pot at that time what about romeo
Dallaire Romeo did you talk to him I did
at great length and I told you find him
uh he's in Canada romeo Dallaire was the
canadian commander
in charge of UN peacekeepers in Rwanda
and he in some ways a limb Kinney and
figure in a couple ways one a prophecy
in January of 1994 four months before
the genocide in Rwanda would begin Romeo
sent and now famous cable to Kofi Annan
who was then the head of the Department
of peacekeeping operations in New York
saying two things one the militia in
Rwanda the Hutu militia had the capacity
to exterminate at a rate of a thousand
every 20 minutes he said this it's in
writing second thing he said was that
the militias quote new from Somalia that
it would only take the murder of 10
Belgian peacekeepers to secure the
complete unraveling of the UN mission
and de l'air informs this appears and
says well needless to say i'm going to
be disarming the militia i mean we can't
have this a thousand external language
of extermination a thousand every 20
minutes whoa and the response from New
York was very adamant don't confront
don't forfeit neutrality Washington will
never stand for it and I think it was
probably an accurate account of what
Washington had an appetite for at that
time so de l'air was left in this
untenable position of watching the
machetes come in the grenades come in
the importation of these arms the
radicalization of of these militia he'd
here on on hate radio they there was a
Rwandan radio station to just propagated
exterminate Ori propaganda about the
Tutsi cockroaches they call them
sanitize the cockroaches kill or be
killed but also propaganda about the
Belgians and about how the Belgian
peacekeepers were the accomplices of the
Tutsi government and how they needed to
be targeted and so on so he's in this
position watching this escalation with
no power to stop it and one year this is
um april of nineteen ninety-four gym
january 94 is the cable that he sends
april 90 for the killing stars you see
the Hutus brought in it I mean 130 yet
about 550,000 machetes yeah I mean it
was and they said it was just garden
implements but again the radio was
transmitting you know evidence that that
ethnic polarization was being done in a
fashion and demonization of the Tutsi
that in two layers mind anyways was
clearly a recipe
the outbreak of massive fight hang go
back you mentioned Kofi Annan was was
not the head of the UN at that point it
wasn't he was the head of the
peacekeeping office which was a you know
just beneath boutros-ghali and he didn't
interfere in this situation he didn't
the tenancy at the United Nations in the
1990s throughout the 1990s was to was a
mistake and tendency but it was to
internalize the constraints that the
Member States imposed so instead of
saying oh my god let's try to shame the
Member States into doing something about
this let's say my god you know a
thousand every 20 minutes they're going
to target the Belgian help the tendency
was to say we don't want to alienate the
Member States we know what Washington
will give us very little Somalia's just
happened there's a fatigue in Washington
Congress especially with peacekeeping
and a tendency that you know that the UN
was going overboard with Cambodia and
Mozambique and Guatemala and Bosnia
their peacekeeping missions breaking out
left and right and none of them were
terribly effective so we know what
Washington's response is going to be so
in a sense why bother and I think what
they've learned and I think the new
administration of Kofi Annan now is
secretary general I think the good news
is that one lesson was learned which is
externalized those constraints shine a
spotlight where it belongs which isn't
on the United Nations and isn't on poor
roméo Dallaire in Rwanda it is in the
capital's who controlled the purse
strings romeo Dallaire Canadian general
you tell the story about him he things
didn't go well for once he got back to
Canada know and and because what
happened he was he was like lempkin in
that he was a prophet ahead of time and
he was like limpkin in that he was in a
situation where nobody would heed his
please as the genocide unfolded and this
is a killing spree Brian that was faster
than that of the Nazis I mean if you can
believe it with these primitive
implements they were able to kill an
average of eight thousand people a day
for a hundred days the cables from the
US Embassy in Kigali and the journalism
that was done limited number of
journalists were there but they did a
terrific job bringing the story out
Dallaire himself was on the phone with
people in the capital saying please
would you send me help they're
systematically destroying the Tutsi
populus he didn't use the word genocide
initially because he was afraid he would
be accused of crying wolf and again even
though lemke ins intent was to associate
genocide with the intent of the
perpetrator all of our tendencies is to
wait until you a huge number of bodies
before you use the work we just
immediately go for numbers rather than
intent but dallaire and the US officials
who were present in rwanda don't forget
but but when the genocide started were
very adamant that if you had Tutsi on
your ethnic identity card it was a death
sentence it was enough if you had money
and we're to see you could buy a bullet
and delay reported this and and you can
imagine the kind of frustration you're
sitting there there Tootsie at your UN
posts you have 2,500 troops under your
command when the genocide starts and
then unit by unit gets pulled out from
under you because the United States
position it did have a policy throughout
the genocide it wasn't just a Paul it
wasn't omission there was a serious act
of commission which was the United
States insistence that the peacekeepers
be pulled out from under de l'air so to
layer himself is sitting there anything
I need more and he's expecting is gonna
get reinforcements they're
systematically killing all of the [ __ ]
of course they're going to send him
reinforcements and he's informed on
april 20 12 weeks into the genocide that
ninety percent of the peacekeepers under
his command all US insistence are going
to be taken from him and what that means
is Tutsi who had gathered at un posts
under the UN the baby blue and white UN
flag the peacekeepers would leave
through one gate and the militia would
enter through the other and they were so
much worse off than if they hadn't
relied on the promise of un protection
in the first place now where any of the
UN peacekeepers killed they were in
accordance with the prediction that
delayer had made that his informant had
told him guess how many ten exactly what
he had warned on the first day of the
genocide on april seven were they
machete they were initially killed with
gunfire and then badly brutalized badly
disfigured with machetes what's your own
position on this should Americans expect
to have their people sent into a
situation like this no because I don't
think they have any reason to expect
that so far I think that it's very
important not to make the response to
genocide and All or Nothing response
meaning I think the tendency of us
policymakers has been to say you know
we don't want to send our troops into
those icky places therefore let's not
call it genocide let's call it a problem
from hell and let's just look away
entirely and one of the things that I've
come to see over time and I mentioned
this in the context of contrasting the
land of the possible now with that that
Morganthau operated under back in 1915
is that policy we do have this toolkit
we can do everything from high-level
denunciation to threatening prosecution
to freezing Foreign Assets perpetrators
are very greedy they like their money
and they usually are squirreling in a
way in various places you could impose
an arms embargo if you saw those
machetes coming in lifting arms embargo
in the case of the Bosnian Muslims and
take sides with a victim people and try
to on them if you don't want to go there
in Rwanda one of the things to layer
proposed was that the United States use
its technology to jam this hate radio
which was being used not only to
propagate hate but to broadcast the
names and the addresses of the potential
victims you could rally troops from
other countries you could create safe
areas that are actually safe you know
putting a meaningful number of
peacekeepers on the ground and using
these NATO planes overhead and indeed
and I certainly think Rwanda was a case
that was with a you know ten thousand
people a day eight thousand people a day
dying sending US troops as part of a
multinational force absolutely part of
what never again implies who's this
fellow this is Peter Galbraith who was a
staffer on the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee back in 1987-88 when Saddam
Hussein was gassing the Kurds in
northern Iraq this is a crime that one
is hearing a lot about these days in
that you know as enthusiasm for
confronting Saddam increases there's a
tendency to go back to his track record
and say this is a man who gases gassed
his own people Peter Gavras son of john
kenneth galbraith he is the son of the
economy he's a bit of a olympian bit of
an unguided missile yep Peter was mad
and again maybe not the best spokesman
for his cause but a true humanitarian he
went to northern Iraq and noticed in
1987 that all of the Kurdish villages he
had visited her seen from afar actually
three years before no longer existed
that they'd been systematically bulldoze
and as far as the eye could see there
was nothing but rubble where are the
Kurdish or were the Kurdish village this
would have been in northern Iraq they're
Kurds of course in Turkey and in Syria
and inside the countries but this is yes
well inside northern Iraq and Saddam
there was a Kurdish rebellion and
insurgency this was the time of the
iran-iraq war some of these Kurdish
rebels had partnered with Iran and
Saddam's decision was to deal with the
security threat that he faced with
genocide so he made no discrimination
between soldiers and on soldiers rounded
people up in mass a number of villages
were targeted with these terrible
poisons which literally made the sort of
skin peel and sind I mean the most
ghastly form of death that you can
imagine the Peter Galbraith you say did
something that not very many people have
ever done who worked for our Senate
committee um well he did a couple things
one he decided that it was one that we
weren't gonna intervene militarily again
to stop Saddam that was not an option we
were aligned with him Iran of course was
the main enemy in the neighborhood but
Peter understandably came to the
conclusion that giving a man who was
gassing his own people American Farm
credits and manufacturing credits was
probably not a not a desirable way to
send a signal that gassing your own
people is a bad thing to do so what he
did working for Claiborne Pell of the
chair the same for Relations Committee
is drafted economic sanctions again
quite a mild sanction when you think
about this the the toll that Saddam's
brutality is taking on these people but
his feeling was again we're giving him
five hundred million dollars we we the
United States are giving Saddam five
hundred million dollars a year in these
credits that's not if this is how he's
behaving and initially Peter succeeded
in getting this piece of legislation
through the Senate on a voice vote but
it was not long before the combination
of the farm lobby and the Reagan White
House teamed up along with some members
of Congress who themselves really didn't
think it was a good idea to be making
foreign policy on Capitol Hill is the
tendency to defer to the White House of
course when it comes to these matters
but they teamed up to kill this
sanctions package and in fact the year
after this genocide Saddam's genocide
against the Kurds the United States
doubled its credits to Saddam
the only politicians maybe not the only
one one of the few politicians you give
a gold star to his Bob Dole yeah it's
it's a I give him a gold star in Bosnia
he actually doesn't come off terribly
well on Rwanda or on Iraq for that
matter in Rwanda as dallaire is
struggling there on the ground to you
know get some rescue and respite from
outside dole just says that Americans
are out as far as I'm concerned that
should be the end of it and that's his
attitude Iraq he's very friendly with
with Saddam's Kansas farm state the
credit program was good for his workers
Matt was to Don Jose that would Saddam
along with Alan Simpson yes Frank
Murkowski yes exactly there's a Democrat
in there too um perhaps I'm not
remembering but um not a yes not at not
a golden moment for any of those
senators who had golden moments in their
days and doles golden moment and he is
he's the he's in some ways the central
protagonist in the book apart from
lempkin in that he owns Bosnia on the
Senate he becomes the conscience of the
Senate on why what motivated him to get
involved in Bosnia well as is so often
the case and I I wish it didn't have to
be this way but some combination of
serendipity and personal encounter and
like Morgantown with those missionaries
and like lempkin with himself having to
take flight and 49 members of lumpkins
family getting murdered dole of course
had that terrible war injury in world
war two was brought shipped back to the
United States in a full-body cast and a
recuperative plastic surgeon in Chicago
offered to operate on him if he could
get his train fare to Chicago taken care
of famously in Kansas they all chipped
in got him his train ticket fare said
get so goes up to Chicago this doctor
named Pam per click in operates on dole
kyllikki and is himself an armenian
survivor and he regales dole with these
stories of what had been done to his
family and he lost you know his parents
his sisters and he tells doll about one
about the balkans to about the concept
of genocide that Bailey says there's
this guy Lumpkin and he's invented this
word and there's this convention and
keep your eye out for genocide don't
make the Holocaust the standard you know
if has happened through history it has
happened through time and so that's one
thing
that really motivated dole the second is
that as a result of this sort of seed
having been planted as a congressman he
made a number of trips to the Balkans
and on one of those trips in 1989 he
happened to he visited Kosovo of all
places before anybody heard of cost of a
full ten years before the NATO
intervention there and these costs of
ours came out to cheer him and they
never had a visit by such a high level
American politician and the next thing
coming down out of the hills he saw
these covered trucks filled with served
police and paramilitary units and these
guys came out with their trenches and
their tear gas and they just started
whacking all of these Albanians inside
and doles kind of face pressed up
against the glass he thinking my god the
brutality of this regime so from that
point on while the rest of us were sort
of reading myself included atrocity
reports with a kind of glazed I effect
dole has in his mind these trenches this
tear gas and these helpless Albanians so
beginning under the Bush administration
when Baker didn't have a dog in the
fight dole had a dog in the fight he
called for confronting the Serbs using
airstrikes lifting the arms embargo
against the Bosnian Muslims and then was
very consistent under Clinton but the
thing that makes stole different unlike
all the other upstanders is that he
succeeds in turning genocide into an
issue for American domestic politics no
other upstander had ever succeeded in
doing that and he does it by taking
advantage of number one the fact that
the genocide lasted three and a half
years that you had a steady you know
consistent coverage in the major
newspapers in the New York Times The
Washington Post consistent editorial
support for intervention William Safire
and Anthony Lewis actually agreeing on
something for for three and a half years
you had Jewish groups teaming up with
human rights groups grass tops and
grassroots advocacy and in July of 1995
when the massacre in sirenita took place
and 7,000 Muslim men and boys are
murdered in cold blood in a ten-day
period effectively on television I mean
we sort of covered it all right down to
the to the the residue of the killing
and the refugees describing the killing
dole uses that to secure on Capitol Hill
a lift of the arms embargo against the
Bosnian Muslims and the climactic scene
of the book is Clinton on the putting
Green realizing the dole a presidential
challenger senate majority leader has
succeeded in making foreign policy on
Capitol Hill has humiliated the
president and is ensured that American
troops are gonna have to get involved
with drawing European peacekeepers and
Clinton's screaming and he says I'm
getting creamed we've got to stop the
killing I'm getting creamed Bob Dole and
others but with him at the lead as a
American influential decision maker
turned the occurrence of genocide into
something that was actually politically
costly for an American president and
that had never happened before in the
minute we've got left let me ask you a
couple technical questions he said how
many interviews did you do for the book
what um I don't know I think somewhere
he's at 304 interviews for this book
sorry I thought you meant promoting the
book oh yeah more than more than 300
with us with Americans and then
thousands with correct me if I'm wrong
in your footnotes so there's hardly a
reference to an interview in the back
yes why um well really no good reason I
had all the footnotes to all the
interviews but I am I ended up deciding
just as shorthand to introduce the
quotes with the present tense as a way
of signaling that it came from an
interview because I was already getting
such complaints about the number of
footnotes that I had you say that you
got a grant from George Soros is open
society institute for what um to travel
to these countries this is a book about
America more than it is about the
specific genocides but the only way to
understand what the human stakes are our
two in fact interview victims bystanders
and perpetrators in these countries in
question and Soros and re and I are the
head of the open society institute
enabled me to travel to these far-off
places we have not a second left thank
you very much Samantha power is our
guest and this is the book it's called a
problem from hell America and the age of
genocide thank you very much thank you